c'est un sujet qui un an après la
disparition du créateur karl lagerfeld
commence de plus en plus à intriguer qui
va hériter de lempire laissée par ce
couturier de génie si durant de longs
mois la rumeur selon laquelle c'est sa
chatte choupette qui hériterait de
l'ensemble de la fortune du kaiser
aujourd'hui plusieurs proches de la star
sortent du bois pour annoncer qu'elle se
trouvait elle aussi sur le testament
c'est le cas de baptiste giabiconi qui
dans une interview au magazine sept à
huit a expliqué qu'il allait hériter
d'une partie de l' empire lagerfeld vous
êtes le premier héritier dunk à la
garçonne une place de choix qui créerait
quelques jalousies dans l'entourage de
carla car il faut dire qu'avec ses
demeures sublime à travers le monde ces
oeuvres d'art ces différentes pardon de
multiples sociétés un patrimoine estimé
à 200 millions d'euros il ya de quoi
avoir envie de figurer sur ce testament
si on sait qu'il ya sept personnes qui
ont été désignés par le kaiser pour le
moment l'inventaire n'est pas encore
terminée et la répartition n'a pas
commencé mais voilà face à une telle
fortune et à des enjeux d'une telle
importance l'annnonce de cette
répartition pourrait bel et bien créé un
véritable conflit entre les héritiers
alors selon vous se dirige-t-on vers une
guerre de l'héritage alors baptiste
giabiconi donc qui a dit qu'il était un
des l'un des bénéficiaires du testament
faire de cas lagerfeld et l'ags a fait
sa fortune et s'estime à combien mais
rien alors on parle de 301 millions
d'euros mais c'est beaucoup plus en fait
j'avais d'ailleurs on dit on va parler
d'un millier déjà il a une baraque à
monaco qui fait 600 mètres carrés où je
sais pas si vous connaissez le prix du
mètre carré à monaco sont très sombres
ou voilà donc c'est énorme
il a énormément d'oeuvres d'art qui
exploite donc il n'y a plus qu'à l'île
de man is gagné 10 millions d'euros par
an quand il était chez chanel donc on
peut estimer effectivement la fortune a
beaucoup plus que ça refuse qu'on m'a
dit on m'a dit que la fortune de karl
lagerfeld c'est environ un milliard
d'euros on a les mêmes chiffres mais
rien me voyez qu'on est d'accord sur
plein d'autres et demain j'espère que
public.fr c'est un style enfin un instit
myriam palombes à cyril hanouna
s'unissent pour l'instant
non mais c'est important
alors oui ça l'est l'anjou les rajouts
simplement qui a effectivement de
l'immobilier il ya deux ans billy
également des oeuvres d'art des
peintures extraordinaires qu'il avait
acheté des sociétés les les aussi le
parfum et la famille est tout un tel
motif fendi les boutiques de la gravelle
voilà est décédé depuis un an maintenant
et donc bâti giabiconi écrit un livre et
sur ce livre on peut voir par exemple
sur le lit se retrouver une enveloppe
monogrammés kahel karl lagerfeld jeudi
ouverte elle contenait un mot de faux
des citations il me remercier d'avoir si
bien travaillé quai voltaire avec la
feuille se trouve un chèque de dix mille
euros
car la justifier en salaires pour ma
génial séance du matin puisque bathie
seras content que karl lagerfeld a
organisé un jour en cachette une séance
photo avec lui dans son appartement et
il y aurait envoyé un chèque de dix
mille euros
et ça c'est vrai que c'est un des
passages qui choque énormément est ce
que ça vous choque
la table non non non non mais non c'est
vrai qu'il était extrêmement généreux
généreux avec avec baptisme je peux vous
donner un exemple nous gâcher fois qu'on
voit un papier sur sur bâti giabiconi la
rédaction en chef avait le droit à un
énorme bouquet de fleurs pour nourrir ma
faim pour nous voilà parce que parce
qu'il était il le protège et énormément
après oui effectivement c'est choquant
et je sais que voilà il lui a offert
beaucoup de voyages il en est lors des
longs trajets les retards la gaffe
pourrait coûter une anecdote un jour on
a parlé de lui à la radio avec valérie
bénaïm c'était chaud ropraz et le
lendemain qu'ils allaient envoyer un
tailleur car la dir weh une jolie
chemise car voilà donc avec un petit mot
est extrêmement et le dow est le genre
de manger parler de la vache qui rit
j'ai reçu de la machine à rouler il
avait séparé alors avec ce qui vous
reste à faire que je vais recevoir plein
de qui les chéris juste les rumeurs très
vite la presse s'interroge sur l'intérêt
lol la relation entre baptiste 21 ans et
karl lagerfeld 73 ans qui est une
immense star et il en parle batiche
amicaux ni dit en gros passé pour gays
ne pas être gay ou peut-être bien que si
on s'en fou qu'on s'imagine tout et
n'importe quoi entre carl et moi je
trouvais ça chouette donc il n'a jamais
voilà infirmer ou affirmé voilà toutes
les rumeurs qui a pu avoir un
myriam alors nous on l'a interviewé à
plusieurs reprises effectivement à
chaque fois il a il a démenti être très
proche de karl lagerfeld
après leur relation était extrêmement
ambiguë quand on lit libre à un moment
il dit je suis heureux d'avoir fait
jouir l'homme et l'artiste
on choisit pas ses mots par hasard quand
même donc voilà la relation était
compliqué on fait pas non plus des gros
câlins à son père sur le considérait
comme son père s'en faire alors quand
même un peu bizarre on va revenir sur
tout ça dans les instances d ivoire qui
a des révélations incroyables
myriam ont parlé de l'héritage de karl
lagerfeld puisque devant les caméras de
7 à 8 baptiste giabiconi a révélé qu'il
était le principal héritier de la
fortune colossale de karl lagerfeld
on va voir cette image est juste après
vous avoir deux trois révélations dont
le livre qui sont complètement folle
sais pas car n'avait pas d'enfant c'est
lui qui a choisi ses héritiers il ya
combien d'héritiers principaux sur ce
testament y en a 7 et vous figurez parmi
ces personnes tout à faire vous pouvez
me dire à quatre positions votre nom est
situé le plus beau le plus haut ça veut
dire que vous êtes le premier héritier
de karl lagerfeld
oui on sait exactement actuellement quel
est le montant de l'héritage
non pas du tout immobilier mobilier art
société finance sas roncquois en
dizaines de millions d'euros ça se
compte en centaines de millions d'euros
je sais même pas moi alors c'est vrai
que ça c'était une incroyable révélation
d'un taux net est donc libre il est il
écrit un livre qui sort aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que leur relation elle est
complètement folle de ce combat dans six
puisque 1 il raconte ce jour au karl
lagerfeld a fait allusion à l'amour de
sa vie
jacques bachère mort du sida en 89 et il
vit tu sais baptiste aujourd'hui tu as
franchi une barrière une limite que tu
es le seul à avoir franchi depuis
jacques est ce que tu as conscience de
ça alors est ce que karl lagerfeld était
amoureux de baptiste giabiconi en secret
ce que c'était un amour impossible et
est un amour impossible clairement entre
les deux après bâti giabiconi les il est
hétéro pour ce que j'en sais mais
mais oui c'était un amour impossible
entre les deux relations hyper ambiguë
et on va pas pouvoir tout dire parce
qu'on aura procès ici mais voilà c'est
mais il en dévoile énormément aux
baptisés ans déjà que je connais bien et
je viens voilà qui n'était pas du tout
ensemble voilà mais il dit car les mais
bien des câlins au point de les faire
durer un peu plus longtemps avant de se
reprendre
il me tapoté l'épaule sans relever les
yeux s'écarter au bord des larmes ça
c'est vrai qu'il fait des révélations
franchement il y va il dit j'ai aimé
karl karl m'a aimée je laime toujours là
où il est à présent je pense que lui
aussi mais mon corps c'est très beau
hein c'est beau très bon t'es beau mais
ça va ça confiait rapaces convives
alors il finit à la fin du livre il
écrit un message très fort il dit un
jour tu leur diras c'est presque fait
mon carnet avec moi car la joie en tant
qu'homme et en tant qu'artiste une
dernière fois longtemps plus de dix ans
que nous nous sommes jamais toucher
autrement comme comme un père et un vice
voilà pour mettre fin à toutes et à
toutes les rumeurs
bah ouais d'accord mais bon moi je parle
pas de bon père en disant voilà oui un
peu particulier quand même excusé mien
qui sont un peu évidente identifiables
on a du mal à peut-être à labelliser la
relation qu'ils avaient et j'avais un
amour vous voilà il n'y a peut-être pas
de mots pour le décrire
alors il faut savoir que la fortune de
karl lagerfeld il possède un appartement
de 350 m² quai voltaire ce en plein
coeur de paris
certains experts estiment cet
appartement ultramoderne à 9 millions
d'euros minimum
il avait vendu dans les années 2000 une
partie de ses meubles aux enchères
l'ensemble est estimé à 30 millions
d'euros
il est en contrat à vie chez chanel et
recevez par an plusieurs millions
d'euros de la marque dix millions dix
millions exactement car la guerre fait
de posséder plusieurs voitures de luxe
une rolls royce à 4 mais lamborghini
400000 un hummer à 60000 euros que j'ai
déjà vu dans paris karl lagerfeld 0
procède aussi comme l'avait dit
plusieurs appartements à monaco voilà il
dure la villa qui est énorme
exactement et baptiste a fait de
nombreuses shooting entièrement nue avec
karl lagerfeld et soumet encore de la
réflexion que karl lagerfeld lui a fait
la première fois qu'il a vu son 6
cylindres à fond et puis de fil en
aiguille vous demande de faire quelques
photos nues et sa première impression
quand ils vous découvre en tenue d'adam
c'est que ça lui fait bizarre vous
pouvez nous raconter pourquoi oui c'est
drôle dit
demande avec beaucoup beaucoup de
notions de précaution exactement de
bienveillance ça vous embête si on fait
quelques photos nues et donc à ce
moment-là en 2008 mais je t'en dit je
tendais un petit peu de près les parties
intimes est donc là ils me trouvent là
mais que ça ressemble à un tuyau
d'arrosage
alors voilà donc c'est vrai que les
formes d'amalgamés coni de dire ça avec
autant de fraîcheur autant de
révélations incroyables artistes oui
alors dans le livre et dans sept à huit
il parlait du travail des exécuteurs
testamentaires qui vont devoir estimer
la fortune globale il faut savoir que
karl lagerfeld était un entrepreneur
donc il prenait des parts dans certaines
sociétés dire quand il est une
collaboration pour une marque par
exemple y avait des espaces résidentiels
qui faisait ou des projets d'hôtels à
macao
il prenait départ et ça ça va mettre des
années à être discernée il ya beaucoup
d'argent et c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est que ce sera dans longtemps qu'il
pourra y avoir une répartition du
capital mais déjà ils vont prendre déjà
le cas pour l'iphone en outre
l'estimation globale oui bien ces
notaires toi maintenant